I'll also spelling bee to up girl in
fifth grade who got pregnant
[ __ ] swear to God
this girl named Holly Noor big Halina I
think was a full any problem
[Music]
I see a hair pop out I light it on fire
and from the other hair show what
happens to a quitter
it's permeate like Band of Brothers I
feel like if one goes down it really I
want to send in Matt Damon like save it
I want to say thanks like it's really
it's gotten to the point where I need
them so much but the funny thing is
you're known for your cool hair and yeah
everyone likes your hair by the way hair
your cool looking new but hair is 80% of
being cool that's cool Pyrus hair is a
big deal yeah and you have good hair but
I didn't know you had any trouble yeah
see you don't thank it but when you're
living with their they see the crop you
see what you see some [ __ ] forest
between the trees and you know more than
anyone my nice look at the miracle what
and other people start to think you're
crazy and then once you start obsessing
on it you just get more and more
obsessed easy to obsess about that's a
hair is a great one because the people
that have here there's bums it's better
hair than me [ __ ] bums and I'm like
daintily drying my hair with a napkin
meanwhile they're like rubbing a rock on
it every morning then and it just gets
better you know what I mean yeah like
you see bums it's not bums whatever
they're called no but outdoors yeah
doors he got Highway Latif under the
freeway and they look cooler I wanted to
do pimp my bum yeah where you go there
and you clean them up they get like some
kids to clean them up for college credit
and then they try to get him a job it
was a necklace or something well not
good see in Sedona bottom bunch of
Justin West what just gonna matter cause
neck let's just say a man it's gonna
flip your life oh yeah I could see that
day my mom was out in Tucson and she's
definitely turning like a real turquoise
junkie yeah my mom loves turquoise I
think mom's love turquoise
yeah it's pretty funny how they my mom
is a squash blossom necklace from
Gilbert Ortega's that's like I'm from
Arizona and they have a lot of Indian
you know real Indians yeah that they do
they make jewelry so this has a lot of
silver and turquoise and like a big
horseshoe in the middle mm-hmm it's
pretty crazy because they were worth a
lot I
she made me hold one once in my car when
I was a little dirt ball and therefore
good luck they're just there for good
looks and you know very decorative
Indian jewelry and then I left it my 62
Volvo when I ran out of gas I left it
for three days because I couldn't you
know when you're it's hard to take a
necklace with you out of ya if you don't
get together you got I just walk
practice and I'm like I can't get back
to the next day to get it and I'm
working so I finally get there and I
didn't realize my door has no locks
someone stole it uh-huh and I had to
tell my mom she's crushed yeah and not
have AZ did you ever go look for a
duplicate of it to try and have it I
don't have any money but yeah I mean I
see him in those stores I just I just
waited and then I bought her a house
later oh they took a long time yeah the
old buying the mama house is really the
peak of showbiz where you go if I can go
long enough and make enough where I can
get her a place if here you know in your
mom my mom is the best so enter you
paying and now when you do that do you
pay you're buying the house outright
there's no payment on it um and this one
I bought it outright but first time I
borrow some was a car mmm I waited til I
could get it out right cuz I didn't want
another payment so yeah well like I
wasn't ready if I had to do all the
payments that a repo it is embarrassing
when they buy your mom's a jacket back
you should show gets canceled yeah
you're living there now my mom's like
someone stole my jag where I'm like I
wouldn't report it yeah best thing to do
is not report it you haven't parked
because it's a repo man comes yeah yeah
do not mean get nerve but this hair for
some reason it started to take over all
my thoughts and everything it's like
started to so I'm gonna get some taken
out of the back there this guy dr. Kagan
in Beverly Hills and I'm gonna get him
taken out and put in yeah there's a lot
of good guys and they've got it down to
a frickin science yeah there's like a
robot comes in
but I can't say names but there's people
I know that do it and we just speak it
but Johnny Farley I will out him because
he got about you know a hundred one of
the Farley brothers yeah he's kind of
like he's kind of pretty much horseshoe
bald you know he got hit hard mm-hmm but
he went in there Dennis Miller used to
say this guy's got more plug
the last two minutes of Carson and so I
yeah he put them in there but they like
go straight in the air and someone I
have him on the show he just he like
spits on it and goes makes it go
straight up he looks like that [ __ ]
clown and it and norm outed him the
other night and said oh I saw that
episode and he's doing that it's a car
and yeah he goes yeah right in the
middle of it we're doing some phony bit
where Johnny's the PA yeah with Kurt
Busch and then Norma's hey Johnny your
plugs really working it tonight and he
just talks and goes thanks normal get
back to the vet now his head is spinning
going you just tell everyone but plug
that guy I mean yeah but that guy all he
has it's like 19 hairs like it's almost
like a fantasy lineup that he put into
his head it looks like he's got the bear
men skeleton crew in there definitely
the night shift I was on SNL and I knew
a guy there that got something way way
back and they were like four manhole
covers they put on your head it was like
each one at like a hundred airs sounds
like a doll you know but I think like
girls that boob jobs guys with hair it's
just mandatory at this point I mean I'm
still shocked girls do lips and no one's
even embarrassing well they're just like
I'm doing [ __ ] everything the claw
and stay in my 20s or yes or 40s or
whatever it is yeah I feel like
sometimes that all that stuff and the
girls get makes him look older you know
who some of them makes him look a little
lumpy like they've been like a nuts kind
of Ennis like a you know some ladies
face could seem kind of uneven sometimes
the older lady sometimes there are eyes
will start to get float a bit yeah
you're like whoa because it's like they
sleep on their side and their eyes an
inch higher and that doesn't settle till
around noon yeah it's not plastic
they're not allowed in the ocean there's
so much in their face if you want to
catch them I d'Hiv you gotta hit them
but speed eleven and one yeah nothing
like it's even up tilting the other way
now
I get it but I don't even really you
know we make fun of it on the show of
anybody but he says we do I would do the
same thing was it nerve-racking have a
norm and I felt I felt anxious or you
like norm and Leno because no one's such
a one throwing dynamite in like a change
yard I checked ahead at norm like Solano
and you know Leno is a great guy I've
got his show million times in the old
days and he was a great comic he got on
Letterman and was doing some of your
members are young but he was a guest I
loved him and he was so funny and very
edgy that Letterman you know put him on
so much and then Carson put him on I
think then he was guest hosting cars oh
wow but when he has another be a full
host on Carson took over then he got a
little bit of flack from comics for
being not like sellout but you know have
a little jealousy but like people are
like he had to tamper down a bit which
you have to I mean if he's on a network
show yeah so they gave them agree for
that and then the whole Conan thing
which is hard you know I didn't really
take sides of that Lana's always been
nice to me I love Conan so I tried to
stay out of that one doesn't really
affect me and then Leno called me after
about you know week on the air to say I
watch every show I love the jokes
there's more jokes per minute anything
on TV the algorithm is great you don't
talk about politics you don't get in
that tense arguments you don't make
people feel cringy watching like it's
your for this now they suddenly hate you
and I said that's the idea is that mean
ideally that's what we're trying to it
I'm too stupid for politics I don't
really want to get into it everyone else
is that one's better at it I got Trevor
right before me and better at it so I
just want to [ __ ] around have fun like
it's almost a pot of cats like buddies
hanging around and try to cram jokes and
then make them look fluid and half up
more fluid because you don't know what
the other guy's gonna say he's he just
roll with it yeah and then what get what
we're getting to you is in Jay said if
you want me to come on I'd love to and I
said of course you know he's a guy that
is just a joke machine that's what we
need and then the idea of who do I put
him with you almost don't need anyone
right that's what I was thinking I was
like wow it's really nice of him also
to go and just be me say oh we want to
be the top banana but to be just a you
know a banana in the bunch anyway you
know also you know in the comedy world
like I've I see a comic on the road when
you're on the road it's usually you talk
to other comics right oh I know this guy
oh yeah he middled for me here oh I used
to open for Dennis Miller you know we
all talk [ __ ] just talk kameena stuff so
comedy is something where I could even
walk up the side and fell in the old
days and if you're a comic and you're on
that list and you just tell us when your
comic they sort of treat you equally
they're pretty cool most comics you're
in the club with famine they're nice
right I mean like I try to be at the
store there's guys there doing better
than me guys are doing worse but you try
to just treat them with the same because
you're all in the comedy world and we
all know how hard it is we all know this
guy could blow up [ __ ] tomorrow
and you could work for this guy the next
day because it's just how it is that's
crazy and now an out tough the world is
so I think Leno is old school saying hey
you tell me you want me sit on that
panel with a bunch of comedians I'll say
with comedians and [ __ ] and I think
he likes me a comedian still yeah and we
make him feel part of the group yeah we
have Martin Short coming up and I'm like
maybe put Maya Rudolph with him because
she's funny and weird maybe just have
those two yeah cuz they goof round I
might want to do a Q&A soon have people
ask from the crowd Oh that'd be great
just fun me know I want it to be longer
I know you know what I think it feels
fast which is ultimately a compliment
right it's good yeah it'd be good to be
going yeah get it done make people want
more I think what it is is like if I go
on Allen I'm probably doing 15 minutes
out there you know at least sometimes
longer like show go just do the whole
show cuz I see why now it's it's
relaxing for her she just goes how was
your weekend lights a cigarette that I'm
like anyway I went to the Rolling Stones
concert right I just go on and on and on
and she's like okay let's go to
commercial that's better for her and I
and I understand that and then because
sometimes doing the show is a hoax which
I've never hosted
I don't want to go interview people
really I just want to shoot the [ __ ]
with comics and laugh so like the hard
part is they only get a little bit of
time you know Rypple and give three egos
a little bit there's always a little ego
when you're sick
in there sure and Chelsea you know
handler did it and she did it well but
but I think she made herself sort of
traffic cop it's easier you mean you say
which I could see doing that you just go
you guys are the funny one like just go
I'm gonna chirp in when I feel like it
yeah basically here's the question what
do you think of this and then they go
and it'll I'm sure turned into some form
of that but I like to throw in jokes now
so now it's like four people right yeah
cuz you're yeah you're coming into it's
not yeah yeah it's like you chopped
liver and so we don't need people that's
the decision I like chopped liver that's
a good let's have you ever had it it's
still out there no but I just pictured
it sounds the gross people I guess hate
him because everybody's like it's always
like the last thing it gets a bad rap
yeah you know I was kids a batter up
fish when people go this smells fishy
because I feel like bad for the fish
because he goes yeah like Oh
fishies by the way the grossest thing
you could smell no like I am a fish yeah
why is that gross I'm just smelling like
yeah I'm on they don't yes menu to other
fishes they it's cool but the other two
humans ate some time I wonder if fish
are male or female here on my plate
you know it's across my mind man oh you
asked who the hell asked the waiter home
and they're like let me check working
there sometimes at that point that's
funny they should leave the village
because they don't get that a lot I'm
sure like [ __ ] are you eating fish
dick how do you get this out yeah maybe
I was eating fish sticks instead of fish
sticks is it yeah I just want to know
what I'm making sure I'm not fish dicks
man fish sticks were good member though
I mean in the lazy mom [ __ ]
dictionary it's so perfect
or the kids who you would have to make
me something to you ever have to make
your own ur your mom made them the
greatest thing is you could be a lazy
mom mm-hmm and what you're doing is
giving your kids a dream like if she
goes all right fish sticks and I'm like
she did it it's my birthday yeah
meanwhile she's like [ __ ] throw that
got him cookie she put an eighth of
those [ __ ] on there dude pizza' rolls
we had fish sticks the easiest [ __ ] and
I loved it so much pizza rolls isn't
really a dinner I think fish sticks at
least you have that element of you know
you got a protein on one of your meal
you're definitely fish in there one of
the food yeah [ __ ] 90% breading yeah
I said I liked that fish I go to
McDonald's and I go through the
drive-thru and I go what's the
filet-o-fish of the day and they go
excuse me and I go is it branzino is
it's not swordfish again and they go
they just pause and I go quarter pounder
with cheese like okay corner pouch is
they just do one thing about fish dough
is some of them have those little bones
in it and they never they never act like
they do you know I'm talking about like
the sometimes you'll get a part of the
fish they're like oh there's eight
little bones
grotesque yeah the hard part about fish
is I see them first of all when they
bring the fish with the head to the
table I'm [ __ ] out yeah I don't want
to see him or why me Jamaicans Gary
Jamaican I don't like that it's
sickening I don't like eating the
eyeball which please call it a delicacy
I mean I like when they need to label it
a delicacy you're not tricking me well
dude even when they give you the head
you don't eat the eyeball you just leave
it in there I don't know some people
like other countries they think
different parts are great yeah I mean
I'm sure [ __ ] we eat is gross but I'm
used to it now I don't think I can start
with some of the stuff they eat yeah
it's too late in the game like a
liverwurst as a kid and I liked it
somehow my mom snuck that in there and
then I like it with mustard on toast but
today I wouldn't start with liver away
yeah we used to get a cut of spam every
now and then to cut him on spam and that
[ __ ] was fire boy that guys are good I
don't know what it is dude it's real
mean if you is it food yeah man is it
outside the for food I would say it's
orbiting yeah yeah of a sin it was good
man I mean it you know I used to get a
horny for wisdom
devil's food because I heard commercials
and it sounded good but I don't even
know what it was devil's food yeah have
you ever heard of that are you allowed
to talk I Anna okay devil's food cake
yeah Deb well there's devil's food cake
what is um is devil's food something
devil's food is nothing it's nothing I
think it's some fire thinking of uh not
spam but there's something also like
I'll get to it but it's sickening
there was talk torpor something no there
was uh
I'm talking how you know but I'm just
thinking all the gross food a hogshead
cheese was popular when I was young you
go over there and go at lunch we had
yeah and watch a lot of older people sit
down on a bench and eat it that's all I
like the scenario you put it in a
setting and I would minds bro I would be
and they'd shape it into a little Hulk -
back in the day for you
they'd shape it - it you know like a
whole you know like a swine like Oh
gross sir I had I would my big thing was
this is why I'm malnutrition and [ __ ]
barely alive is that I grew up and
didn't have one [ __ ] glass of water
about 22 years that wasn't a thing yeah
even in the desert only if you're going
to the Desi's bring a canteen but yeah
but I did if you lived there that's
crazy weren't big on that and what what
it was when you know more about food now
I woke up in the morning I went to
school my mom went to work so I would
eat cereal which is like yeah you know
fruity pebbles or something you could
not lose you went to grab any of my
cereal boxes Captain Crunch 10 out of 10
Wow [ __ ] King vitamin I was an old
one Apple Jacks life did you do that one
- well that's a seven out of ten it
wasn't sugary enough right
I need Count Chocula I need the basics
for a while and then I remember Seinfeld
once said cookie krisp is a now it's
just a bowl of cookies I mean we gave up
you're giving your kids the ball cookie
so I'd go so that's all the sugar right
right drink the milk whole thing go to
work I'm gonna go to school got there
early grab some M&Ms or a cinnamon roll
oh wow your sugar sugar sugar sugar
lunch cheeseburger fries coke and then
at school I blacked out once our big
thing was mean by that like I just
blocked out at school playing basketball
and then I went to the doctor and I
blacked out again a couple days later
and they said you either have leukemia
or low blood sugar and the bets were on
and I want up with low blood sugar so I
thought oh I need more sugar yeah I
didn't think that would be what you need
yet a trachea so I'm or passed out again
and
I started drinking Diet Pepsi in high
school which was a little yeah it's a
little it's a little iffy yeah I
couldn't even see a young man having a
can of that let's just say in high
school didn't fly but I had to couldn't
you sure they said no more sugar I was
like you are [ __ ] kidding so must
have been nerd alert we're kids like
Jesus dude not a drill mu major nerd
alert affecting all four counties in
Arizona all the other schools heard
about it so I'm sitting there eating but
I still would have liked I only have 10
cookies today like this is I was cutting
back but my body was not getting a
nutrition when we were eating good food
at night I swear to God it was [ __ ]
Lean Cuisine that was our video yeah
which today would probably make me sick
it's in it's a ziploc of gloop
yeah with a glop e-fit you know I just
sold in it it has good salt in it has a
lot of good salts it's a good is it
really the good kind of salt is just so
but definitely my mom had one last night
he did I couldn't even talk to her she
was Wolfen in kuzey no TV dinner oh
that's so every now and then she likes
to get a little TV dinner over there
her mom is she around yes she was in
Tucson oh that's right you said she's
out there did I still live in Tucson do
we had a mailman when I lived there he
would drive my late off hours bro and
[ __ ] furious at his head his wife you
know the yelling [ __ ] about her even
though she wasn't in the mail truck and
[ __ ] throw the mail I would he be mad
at you yeah or just anybody just
throwing the mail out into the yard not
even using the box
I love anger you know the kids today I
guess we do still have mail man I forgot
now it's like it's just somebody that
kids everybody reports him always as
like pedophiles predators it's like they
don't get a good rap out there if you're
still like yet traveling around doing
stuff everybody like I saw a guy
yesterday and he was just like a comment
like a construction worker yeah and I
was like oh man that guy might be a
sexual predator you know there's no
reason other than the fact that he's an
oddball job or something yeah that he's
just gainfully employed yeah and like
walking home what about all those jobs
are they get around kids it's like a
bonanza what if you're a wrestling coach
in high school like you know you just
wrestled kids yeah
slap money ass all day you never know
that's like volleyball coach oh you're
getting busted
yeah way you're being around all those
chicks are not chick young ya know all
those jobs were
I mean gymnastics but I think they're
onto that one but you just I just look
back and go how could you there's so
many pervs
yeah I remember like we had pervs did we
had a couple pervs that I was going half
on went to jail I think my friends a
child molester you know right I want to
get more data before I hand them in
because it's only a hunch right now I
went to his house he's watching the
Little League World Series oh yeah I
don't like it you know and then I tried
to give him an outtake are you are you
one of you you know this one of the kids
and he goes now he goes but look at
those calves man these are athletes I
got they're not really they're 12 yeah
and you can't see their calves either a
lot of them have long pants yeah I know
it's just dreaming about it I think yeah
just kind of guessing leg MUSC but I
will tell you I can honestly say little
girls little kids are cute just cute
yeah and something that's extinct you
cannot say that you see anybody with
their kid or they got a seven year old
and I go uh your daughter's cute huh and
then they like shuffling way I like it
what do you like I'm an creep oh yeah
and they handsome yes if it's very
handsome child that's had two oh you
said oh a girl a girl yeah I'm like wow
so handsome
you know kid hopefully it's an adult
soon is hard it's a hard because you
know I said say hey listen I'm no child
molester yeah I'll leave me for not
starting with your kid yeah she's not
that good I'll start with that kid I
thought that Carnival three nights ago
short pants on that's number one or with
a nice Latino kids back hair your kid is
down the waiver wire I'm telling you
yeah let's start with this pace yeah
she's no JonBenet no I think happened
with JonBenet why do I love anything
about John it's too well first of all I
feel like you and her almost have us
there's something about you guys both
kinky
nice hair talented talented showman
showman showmanship working through the
Tykes tanning the you know the test of
time kind of likes continuing to stay
relevant it's true Jon Benet is still
more famous than me which sucks right I
was a little am i Yankee Doodle
I was a little bit of that a little look
at me kid were you really attention
seeker did you do any you didn't do
chorus or anything at school did you
because that is renowned I was straight
but what happened was no I was I think
as my dad left us when I was 4 I look
back to think is that why I was always
like entertaining yeah thinking maybe
he'd see you gross I don't know that's a
good angle though because I used to get
throw fits I had a bad temper not smash
trophies in my room
this is just look at this white button I
don't know that's white privilege bro
that's just but what is this mash your
boss no I said I had any trophies I had
one trophy
I had a participation true dude I got a
trophy one time as a plaque and they
misspelled half the [ __ ] on there from
our school and I was like [ __ ] and that
was your big break
yeah they [ __ ] it up and I lost so
Spelling Bee to ugh girl in fifth grade
who got pregnant swear to god this girl
named holy nor big Halina I think was
her full name problem and dude nobody
thought you could spell nobody thought
you could even speak no one thought she
could get knocked up Jesus so she was a
real overcomer dude or just someone who
accepted calm you know and she sorry
about that part my trophy was for the
shortest first in school I think no way
no I wasn't trophy but I got one for a
little league just for being on some
team but I broke it my mom was like oh
the Brooke are yeah cuz I thought I
think I was mad at my dad left I think I
look back why was I so [ __ ] mad all
huh
you probably have to be if you're a kid
that's all yeah you had you'd have to me
dude it's funny sometimes I think that I
opted you though you were just talking
about that girl that got knocked up oh
ho Lena I don't know what she's doing
guys still stay in touch your nose
no dude convenience and I should've had
a can I still call you did yeah I I lost
I went to state and I thought I was King
[ __ ] [ __ ] I walked in the state
finals like this like some Indian kid
yeah I walked up there I got smoked on
the first word they got a power out as I
go easy a a P a P P they go being gone I
go no no
you can't change it I try to change it
in the middle and Wow Iceland you can't
change once you put a letter that was it
and I think so back in my hazy strict
rules but yeah the rules were a lot
stricter then you what did you lose
inconvenient that's a Telefunken being
it's yeah just and I was showboating up
there everybody was watching dude
finally a couple chicks looked up from
whatever they were like you know the
love letters they were right into my
friend Scott not quite as drenched as
that you thought they because yeah it's
almost spelling convenience yeah nobody
cared in the big hit Lena Park ha ha
look me she comes up free she got that
of all words abortion she was built like
an adult though like that's one thing
you don't see anymore like when I was
younger they had children that were
built like [ __ ] adults yeah you know
I had kids who wore like we had kids who
came to school with just oil stains on
them like they were ready
like in that's they're ready to throw
down ready to go to work so yeah go
right to a garage yeah like undeniable
like half the kids would leave school
and go to work somewhere
even a young ages it seemed like and now
these kids you know it's just different
there's crying meetups there crying
meetups we should have one of those yeah
I mean Sebastian said the other night of
the VMAs that they had a room if he knew
it he's triggered they had a room
backstage for people that okay good yeah
oh he must have a field day without that
were a long time when Sebastian was
doing that I almost wanted to say to him
I don't know well enough I do like the
guy because there's no way to say it but
I did Teen Choice once I host it and I
wrote for Dana at the VMAs and it's just
a tough room I mean they don't give a
[ __ ] if you're over 22 I've even just
presented at them MTV Awards with Aubrey
Plaza and we're like what's our bit I'm
like Aubrey you're funny and knowing as
a [ __ ] they well we can give her our
best [ __ ] out there
they don't care nobody so they had some
guy this guy Noah good-looking dude from
one of the movies it kills on Netflix or
something mm-hmm I've got trillions of
followers I couldn't walk right past my
nose oh well from the Bible I know and
Trevor Noah yes I know this no is
[ __ ] Noah syndergaard bigger than
both all three mmm he goes out there
every chick is there like it was bananas
it was beetles he couldn't even do any
and he did some then he sat on the floor
then they thought that was terrible
this guy's out of [ __ ] jokes or
anybody couldn't do no wrong and then
these girls were just like it was
Katrina they would they were all sliding
off their seats and they were you know
teenager I shouldn't say that they were
some adults 18 years yeah they were 18
and they were horny for turned 18 yeah
then he finally leaves and they
introduce us ladies and gentlemen
basically children would you please
welcome these two [ __ ] [ __ ] so we
walk out they could not give a [ __ ] they
were all mad their faces wait he's still
in the building why the [ __ ] are you
wait we're still applauding we still are
creaming over this guy why are you did
we start talking like now and then I'm
like hey I'll rape love and they're like
shut the [ __ ] up they hate it and
they're blocking me on Instagram guy
just being mind you just a boy who are
you how do you spell it unblocked well
we're you know excuse me I know you was
just talking with David Spade but now I
got to tell you that the holidays are
coming it's that time of year if you go
if you go look around your buddy's house
and look far far away get some
binoculars you might see a reindeer you
might see a pumpkin you might see
Cinderella and I know it's crazy it's
crazy early to talk about the holidays
but you want to have that nice photo
ready smile well then you got to start
now and it's easier than ever with clear
aligners from candid candids aligners
can help you straighten your teeth
faster than traditional wire braces wire
braces what are you keeping sheep in
your mouth no treatment takes just six
months on average
think about your grill man and think
about it looking great
an experienced orthodontist - his
license in your state creates a custom
treatment plan then they show you a 3d
preview so you can see how your teeth
will look after you're done Kandi's
aligners are comfortable removable and
completely invisible you can't see them
it's like a magic power in your mouth
and with each aligner purchased Candide
donates $25 to smile trained who brings
safe 100% free
left lip and palate treatment to
children around the globe beautiful
so get your photo ready smile now and be
ready for the holidays you want to grin
at somebody grin at your friend
Greenwich uncle somebody you might even
be dating somebody in your family grin
at them it starts with a smile you know
and ends with maybe love go to candid
co.com slash Theo and use code Theo for
$75 off that's candid co.com slash Theo
for $75 off candid co.com slash Theo and
now back to the episode dude your
Instagram is uh you do if people don't
know you do some of the best bachelor
coverage I know on IG man it's not
helping my straight case no well
actually the funny thing was I remember
when you invited me over to watch The
Bachelor oh yes or at only had a flaw
and then ya know we had a blast
definitely you also I had to sit on the
sofa you sat behind a chair I didn't
want anything I was making any moves oh
except for murder baby and you're like
why do I need to run I'm in a Pennywise
cos yeah it's like what I do I know I
always back because my [ __ ] back I
can't sit on that couch well dude didn't
don't let have other people sit on it in
fronting like I should tell people
listen yeah just tell him a little me
probably won't get killed yeah cuz all
because I didn't know you're that good
that's right no it was just like all
right and I I was I was like one of
those creepy kids the movies at walks
with my knees go the wrong way and I'm
like don't mind me you're like what the
[ __ ] you know if I see a movie first of
all you never see scary movies if I see
like a little girl in a dress who's like
10 and she has black hair in her face
and she walks with her knees go the
wrong way the joints I'm out there's a
lot of [ __ ] chance I'm seeing that
movie oh she's from outside of the city
limits do we got a question right here
oh we have a question
mm-hmm how does this happen they sent a
man we let him know they were gonna come
in yesterday oh well we need headphones
for this under yeah sure okay go ahead
it's complicated show if it's bad is a
fan of The Bachelor and my question for
him is
if you could change the format be the
new Chris Harrison mix things up what
would you do to change it what was her
name Shelby she didn't say it
she'll be a beautiful of age girl -
she's very calm and her question yeah
she wasn't Fanning out which I sort of
wanted I wanted her to go oh my god I
came to think of my question it's David
Spade yeah I'm so nervous
so nervous to tape this that he might
see one yeah so The Bachelor I do like
what do you like them just for the
stupidity of I don't yeah you know it's
got cute girls I just find him make fun
of everyone ever oh yeah that's why I
like it too actually
and they and every girl knows about it
so if you talk about they have something
talked about he had something in common
and they're all single girls and 29 of
them are losing so you go well you're
gonna run into them a pizza no I know
you don't know a boyfriend so at least
it's not like you're creeping on some
married show yeah look at all these hot
married girls so it's just more for
comedy and fodder but I think I don't
know what I would change is they
obviously have it wired I do like this
new situation which you wouldn't know
what there's a guy named Tyler he's like
a i'ma going this guy's too good-looking
he's on The Bachelor he's vying for the
one girl Hannah I think he's gonna win
it all cuz she's good-looking what he's
a he's a bit of a dud mm-hmm but it's
never stopped any guy from getting later
so he doesn't get picked he's the third
runner-up so they go he's gonna be the
next Bachelor and then in this new crazy
world gigi hadid
says this guy is hot you know wow it's
another dating now they're dating no and
guess what not only dating they're
dating every second of every day you
know couples are like velcro monkeys
like shoot like just together right away
like magnets he went to her grandma's
funeral with the programís you know whoa
whoa whoa so that's very Native American
- my thing is first of all these guys
that have so much free time so a girl
likes you you fly to New York or
whatever I don't worry Lowe's and you
don't leave her [ __ ] sight do you have
one thing to do in the last six weeks
you've been with her a haircut a dentist
appointment
I have [ __ ] natives remember something
you left somewhere yeah you can go hey I
can see this afternoon this morning out
a couple things I gotta work out what no
he has 24 hours a [ __ ] day obviously
not a job yeah they never have jobs they
always quit the job to go on back to
people on The Bachelor yeah this is
Stedman this is like a new Stedman yeah
and look at he's hot though when I left
now he is very handsome oh good at that
funeral look at him he could have yeah
you almost wish the girl mother was a
lot to get a good look at him he said
the grandma was in the coffin and he and
he saw the roses he goes when is she
gonna give him out because he didn't
know what he does know anything else I
get one I'm gonna reject it wow this is
intense
there you go dude he is ripped is it do
you think men are more handsome since
you've gotten older or when you were
younger do you I didn't know what
good-looking guys were growing up like I
couldn't tell now when you get all the
data of what girls like you can start to
say oh this guy's guys handsome I never
look from the well I never look waist
down though you don't do that I don't
know I don't yeah I don't look at this
picture of this man but I will only like
my eyes can't even I never knew that
part because the girl I went out with
said uh about two years ago she goes I
saw it Harry Styles and then she goes
look at this picture when I alright he's
in a suit and she just wears this dick I
go what do you mean just look where his
dick is you can't even see it sticking
out I go
why does dick be popping out of his
pants shoes I all I do is look at guys
dicks all day in their pants I go
[ __ ] really I go no one's my dicks
not do anything in the day like yeah I'm
getting I'm getting screwed on that deal
because I don't want to walk on slapping
together a half a rod just it so some
chick might look for it and you know I'm
doing that before I'll sneak off for I
go in a busy room and just kind of shake
it a little maybe if there's some [ __ ]
going on it's like you're mixing a
[ __ ] milkshake we don't know if I'm
walking out of the Emmys I might get a
couple cc's of plasma [ __ ] [ __ ]
slamming it in the door back yeah I
heard one time I was on this cruise ship
and I was trying to get an erection this
girl was a real [ __ ] land animal you
know and I literally was like whacking
my wiener against the wall trying to get
blood into
god I still remember that I'm the words
in India I'm like a one-trick pony like
that's everyone thinks I'm like whatever
I don't know what they think but where
do you think here you definitely just
Casanova before we get in that do I want
to talk a little bit more what else
would you do about the bats or anything
else because I know me on that question
I could almost see Harrison first of all
we'll never give the job up he is
low-key while he's seeing for these
women
oh I mean and they they have nothing to
an island but sneak in his room yeah
he's on the island too so oh he's I mean
it is boring because you know they pull
him out for three minutes a day and he
has to wear a suit and all that [ __ ] but
I wonder if he's allowed to mingle and
hang out it must be ruled he gets all
their numbers I mean he's got all their
IDs
he's DMing up a frenzy I can you don't
think he's married and then he goes the
bachelor island then he doesn't there he
came on her show and he was cool he's a
great guy he was cool animal couple you
were you on the show with him he was
awesome
wasn't me you and Kaley Cuoco know what
show were you one who was was she
divorced again yet or no no they don't
live together though now that I like
isn't that interesting I think it's a
new I've been trying to pitch that I
think it's true because let me go ahead
I'm sorry we're getting away from her
question but I Kaylee was on I set my
second show you were on really early I
was on the second show and it wasn't
Kaley uh-oh she was on I think the next
day he was on with Jen Kirkman and
another female comment oh look at
[ __ ] [ __ ] Greggy Google over
there's got it bro
I haven't better than Adam egit look at
Collin calls in you see it last night
we've actually got some voice questions
from Adam II get as well we do we have
questions from Adam for us yeah I got it
you do mmm
okay so I'm gonna get one if we like it
oh [ __ ] it's okay so I will get ten
what's the paper towel budget let's you
say and I'll get it okay we'll take it
expired hey it's Adam II get from the
office um do you know where the paper
clips are I really need these like
office as soon as possible
I guess he looks [ __ ] over here also
corn dogs for lunch today so let me know
if you want me to save you one
Calvillo I said hi yeah call me back as
soon as you get this I need to know
about these paper clips like stat I will
tell you at Amin we're still using
there's actually two more from him yeah
and this is wouldn't he write these your
[ __ ] solid yet okay the monologue
good yeah hey it's Adam again do you
know how I changed my W to any amount of
taxes taken out so I always all right
300 dependents hey evening um hey it's
Adam again Spade yeah fire extinguisher
in your office he's all right
just uh get back to me I won the [ __ ]
mess slowpoke Rodriguez fire you know
what happened I yesterday he got a box
of pens sent to him he's got a hall
ffice he's got an office let's say this
is a big square room right this big huge
lot we are doing the showing over on the
wall like that's his desk so everyone
walks this is a Hall of us because he
just want everyone just walks through
and does their [ __ ] writing it like an
office office of the door he sits there
never one just makes fun of him so I he
was someone put garbage on his desk like
these workers came to put on his desk
while they were working and he just sits
there go the [ __ ] is happening so I'm
one of my stories I put on Instagram I
go hey Adam II get hating his Hall ffice
and so this woman that works for a pen
company sent him I mean maybe 300 pens
oh wow they said hey I saw your office
looks needs a little pan action on there
so yesterday he was like coming yard so
he laid them all out and we got to come
pick up Annie don't take the violent
ones take green he's like no no no green
and then everyone's like arguing which
ones they wanted me my 300 yeah but
they're like you only felt if he's like
that he's being snug with some
and he just got him free one minute ago
like now he loves being a UH he loves
the job though it seems like his he's
been he loves he's good at yeah he's a
guy that does the comedian's and we have
another department seems like a total
[ __ ] show but we have a whole department
that does anyone's not a comedian so
like or a get too big like if Leno is a
comedian but we have talent office two
of them just right as you know there's
some people that are more cause I think
Jim Carrey oh yeah we I think Jim
Carrey's coming on there really that's
awesome love Jim Carrey very so tell
interesting dude did you remember um did
you ever remember seeing him as a
comedian um barely just seeing on a
special I think Rodney Dangerfield's HBO
special when he was a young comedian
special those were big they would have a
big comedian come in and host and I have
five new comedians five or six and I saw
Kennison on that I saw we wouldn't Kerry
was there a thing that happened like
whenever you were kind of coming up
through the ranks that you you wished
you had done it or you had gotten it and
you were like oh man this is and you
know everyone should have a career Wow
Star Search they came to my they came to
Arizona to a mall oh you were they
organized Valley Mall I did your mom
take you or did you just go I think I
was old enough to drive went out to PVM
I literally used to drive without my
shirt on I was such a [ __ ] Joe Dirt
starting as Fred wolf lived in Montana
with their balls I live in Arizona we
see guys walking with a long hair and no
shirt on tucked in their back pocket
hole in the gas can oh I love that day
that's a whole life out there so I'm
raising my own guys step that I take my
shirt off whenever I drove because I no
air conditioning so I go to PV yeah
that's why and I stand on some little I
do two minutes of stand-up they check to
see if you have any game no callbacks no
nothing and PB was at Palos Verdes mall
or something with PV Paradise Valley
Paradise Valley at the mall it was at
the mall in front of everybody no like
Tiffany yeah Wow and I think they would
check crowd reaction it's kind of a good
idea yeah it's at least you're getting
some real feedback right there so when I
finally felt like I think you'll know
you you will agree that people say
what's your big break comedy sort of a
series of little breaks like
one club when I was starting that was a
big break yeah and then getting on
another club and then getting at The
Improv when I got in LA was huge then I
got on this H feel young comedian
special which I was talking about kind
of Dennis Miller was owes me Rob
Schneider Drake sailor Fred stole our we
had all these guys in there and everyone
did great and then Rob and I got SNL off
that another big break
Wow Tommy Boy another big break so it's
just really like treading water your
whole [ __ ] career just get you can
never relate let off the gas cuz go away
in two seconds someone even said to me
the other day this Buber guy goes you're
in show biz hangers I love those is
whatever happened to Chris Pratt I go
Chris Pratt did three blockbusters in
the last two years you guys okay I go I
didn't see him I go well this [ __ ]
guy's in trouble what about me I did I
do I know movies on Netflix guy never
saw that I guarantee it I did father of
the year in neon I go well [ __ ] you
don't want to be like it's good to see
ya
I don't know like what people perception
is yeah yeah it's definitely changed all
you have no idea of people to see takes
a year in that gear this which is every
week like I usually want a TV show so
that's every week and so when people
don't see me for a year they're like
what the [ __ ] what how do I take a you
know a year to get a movie off the
ground I right then it takes three
months to film it then a year edit it
and get it out and if you missed that
one now there's two and a half years you
missed me so that's all that work for
one [ __ ] two-hour movie and then you
do another one so have you done some
pretty stinkers have you done some real
[ __ ] ones yeah Oh movies yeah yeah I
think me meant shits Oh No I've done
some pretty bad ones dude I have the one
at worst superpower
I don't know if is a superpower enough
but I know if I walk into a bathroom if
somebody's pooped in there recently
because it's thanks yeah that's not a
superpower by the way can you tell it to
if someone took a dirty [ __ ] dude I
walked out of a bath like the war thing
I hate the most about myself man I just
wish I couldn't do that oh me say it bro
okay that isn't okay I will tell you
though I hate it
I don't know if we need a moment of
silence for that but no I just I
[ __ ] can feel it in my I went to this
nice place the other day for dinner not
that nice but it was a regular
restaurant normal okay well I don't
people think I'm some - dude I be with
you it's only good nice yeah so I go and
I go to the bathroom and this is that
you would relate to this you can see the
camera this is a can't hear it at all
but I go like this I walk in and the
students walking out and I go
oof cuz he should so bad oh yeah and he
stops and looks at me he's what you say
and I go [ __ ] rough dude and he goes
what the [ __ ] I got a knife bust out of
me because I go
am I getting a fight about a [ __ ] that
reeks so bad I have to I thought I had
to say something I walked and I go god
damn like cause like you're the air
defender an ordinate an ordinate ly rank
you know oh yeah I get that it's not a
you know [ __ ] then it's the factory
but you go in there and it's reek so bad
sometimes at Wallops you and you have to
mention it like you can't even hide it
you go oh yeah and then he was offending
as it was him uh so he wanted to fight
me yeah you want to fight me over your
poops well you're also defending the air
bro like Yeah right - do I just want air
I want to be able to live in here so I
had to leave I can't even pee in this
pool it's like oh yeah I hate that man I
hate me I hate knowing that it's I just
wish that I could never sometimes I try
to hold my breath before I go in and try
to just have my breath held the whole
time that I'm in there oh and your poop
town and I think it's a nice restaurant
I go do one time this guy I went in
there one time there was like a kind of
like a herb and gentleman working in
there you know like kind of like a mint
you know with the mints and the yeah you
know doing the sometimes they'll do
scarves and everything they got six cars
everything this guy was a new suit in
there yeah this guy was fresh off the
boat you know and um they clean up in
there
oh dude well here's the thing though
this guy was kind of like a big jock
kind of dude so I go into the end of the
stall right into this little Dookie
booth you know to rock a number two
right yeah and this guy goes uh-oh
alright fam I got you right and I'm like
what does that mean like I think he was
trying to like think like I'm gonna tip
him or something you know
so then another guy comes in better if
you talk to me I think you have to tip
that's the thing once so make contact
yeah the thing then another guy comes in
and tries to get at the door right and
this guy like lunges oh yeah and he's
like hey my man's in there get into a
[ __ ] fight into a shoving match
security comes in the whole deal and you
weren't even pooping you were pissing
like no I was why I can't tell someone I
will sit down a pistol if it's late at
night but this was a I don't know but it
was just so like I'm not with this guy
you know that's so hot that he'd if he
went to mount with you then you go out
there and put a quarter and they all you
know you get me here's how you get me
the tip I walk in they go David Spade I
go up you're getting two cuz I know
you're gonna call tmd know this
[ __ ] took the dirties proof but
he only gave Nanette go huh [ __ ] jockey
who's in there and what time I was bring
your kid to work day now I shut up
that's not possible
I swear to god this is over by UCLA it
was at Mahoney's bar some more they had
over there Maloney's and the guy's got
his son in there laughs hard enough
dressed up like a little seal or
something like a little oyster like I
said you know like a fancy or you know
somebody that's going like a you know a
wedding or dance or something you know
like looking all I got a little not like
an actual oyster yeah yeah not like a
nice is that what you say when people
dress up or like a penguin or something
you know yeah payment we're so far off
penguin make some sense like a little
tux but due to snow oyster how good with
that [ __ ] taste bro what is that
that's one of the same once they find
those you know how expensive those like
in a year those are gonna be something's
gonna be on a menu somewhere snow why
she said I'll put all my money in this
noise um would you change anything else
on the bats all right or no bats are you
trying to go back to her she got a lot
of screen time for that question
we haven't even answered all that of me
gets we don't know paper clips yeah
bachelor I love I um it's it's down
right now the viewership is when does
this come on to
is September 21 2006 today September so
L 14 2006 yeah so to be 12 mm okay yeah
sorry to interrupt this little chitchat
er with uh with uh with mr. Joe Dirt
himself but this can you believe that's
really Joe Dirt that's so wild they I
can't believe that happened to him this
episode is brought to you by better help
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist I remember I was
having a tough day one day and I was
driving and I didn't want to be driving
I didn't want to be thinking or feeling
and I pulled over and I got some dang
help and how to do what I did through
better help you can start communicating
in under 24 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online better
help you can get you can do it through
text you can do it through call you can
do it through FaceTime Skype it's
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches and it'll set you up
with a counselor that's right for you
better health wants you to start living
a happier life today visit better
help.com slash Theo that's B e TT ER h e
LP and join the over 5,000 people taking
charge of their mental health that's
right our listeners get 10% off their
first month at better help calm slash
Theo 10% off your first month if your
brain is not feeling good then this
could be a way you that you could get
some help it's secure you don't have to
walk into an office and it is a unique
method to to get some mental help that I
have used myself it's better helped calm
slash Theo for 10% off your first month
today's episode look everybody needs to
learn something learn how to do
something learn how to hunt a pig learn
how to you know paint learn how to ride
a camel or something or learn how to you
know do a vaginal rejuvenation those
aren't things you can learn at
Skillshare but those are skills skill
share is different it's an actual online
learning community for kriya
with more than 25,000 classes in design
business and more you'll discover so
many ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career take classes in
social media marketing photography
creative writing even illustration learn
to draw something you love somebody in
your family draw them give them a
portrait give them a something do some
art love your friends you want to learn
graphic design try graphic design basics
core principles for visual design one of
their most popular courses join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering tpw listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com / - Theo
von to start your two months now that
Skillshare comm slash Theo von and now
back to the episode uh we don't have a
show today in my show we have we had
Friday we had the skull ours last night
yeah Sully I don't think we talked
enough about Norman J cuz it was it made
me nervous
the show is [ __ ] hot nervous the show
is hard because everyone's got a
different energy and vibe and I don't
sometimes know it one time I had a
female comic and you know Mike going
over to the side and then out of here
she what do you think she goes and I go
oh is that your hook like I don't know
like some could be very dirty some are
timid some were like she's she stayed in
her shell this guy over here is like
super whatever or he doesn't like you
know and then you know I Jaisal Mike
Connolly he's sort of quiet very funny
but he's on with other people and so I
want to make sure he gets time to write
get his joke out and I get stepped on
and then you have some [ __ ] guy you
don't even know on one show later all
laughing too hard and running over
everyone's stuff you know I learn every
show what I like and I'm like I don't
like to pull teeth because there's too
many dead spots you know I like people
to sort of self start last night the
Sklar is perfect Leno perfect I show
picture
Kylie Jenner he's like you know I read
you hear about this yesterday
they say Kim and Connie I gotta get
divorced I don't think he's gonna leave
her behind
yeah aren't they and it wasn't funny but
I was sitting there freaking out going
everyone give him a second on this
because he's old school and he took his
time with it right have you seen this
pause these two might get a divorce and
you just think someone's gonna jump in
on that pause in the now do their line
or comment and I'm like to sleep on and
I've got crazy norm over there so norm
is always very funny and you just don't
know what you're getting and that's part
of the fun yeah yeah I'm watching that
when it was team like yeah you're just
such like like you literally have no
clue what's about to climb out of his
mouth
and I don't listen he can offend me it's
sort of the funny part about it that he
goes after me a little bit I don't want
him to offend the other guests I don't
want if they don't know what they're
getting either and Jays you know he was
very nice to Jay he said nice things but
it's hard and then I had to do the bit
with NASCAR yeah Kurt but it's hard to
do bits in front of comedians because
NASCAR came all the way there to be a
part of it they liked the show
or getting more and more people I call
that want to be on the show and that's
nice that means the show's doing alright
and I'm going to ask our guy I'm a
little bit of a dirt ball so I had met
this guy Kurt and he was game but every
joke we had they killed right before the
show so NASCAR you know they have their
brand and this and that and I didn't
know it so then I was like [ __ ] going
to because now I go what am I saying
because I think one we had the car up
close I go oh is this a make-a-wish car
why is it so close and he goes yeah it
says it has cancer but I think it's
lying and then that's gone so when I get
to the show to about to tape it I go oh
that's gone what's there we put some
else they approve it I'm like I don't
even really know what bit I'm doing now
and that never happens and then we said
oh Johnny the PA I have an I have a
question figured it's John Farley and he
goes I go alright one question he goes
if you have any adderall and I go you're
not asking him that and he was not even
for me
I got he's not know and then Kurt goes
talk to me after the show when I go home
so they killed all that
these aren't the best jokes in the world
it's just don't take away J you know
what I mean we right yes you might wanna
shoot more and then cut it down they
just we should have sent him ahead and
then they can talk and you know there's
always gonna be a barter with someone it
was a lot packed in one episode but most
people like we had Rascal Flatts on last
night and a band Mumford and Sons and
their very game they come on they go I
know it's pays about I'm not there to
make them look bad you're not gonna get
people if you do that so if they want to
roll with some jokes yeah I make fun of
myself half the time so if you like are
you enjoying doing the show are you
finding that you're enjoying it more
than you thought you would are you
having any yeah I think you're it when I
liked now it seems like it's definitely
coming it's hard it's very hard but and
I have cards and cards like roll to this
pre-tape and it isn't we have someone
talking a voiceover and make sure they
get to say this if they want to say
something but to wrangle it all it's
gets easier every show it's but it is
hard it is a job where you wake up 7
a.m. and I have to think all day movies
are really hard but it's more just
legwork being on a set every day laying
around all day memorizing lines
it's memorizing and staying awake and
then the movies are fun but they beat
the [ __ ] out of you this one at least I
go home and I can have dinner right I
can movies I'm on the set all day what
happened at the mall with the Star
Search you got her you didn't get it no
I got I got shine on that and then when
I started to do ok you didn't get it
didn't get it
I'm finally I got to LA couldn't get out
they let you know in the mail they
didn't say jack [ __ ] oh I asked ed
Saranda sponsor from Netflix you know
this guy he's one of the big bosses
there he's from Arizona very cool guy
for that job he's always so cool and
collected I can't believe it one time
somebody a big-name guy I was like host
[ __ ] that guy pitched you a show
and he goes yeah and he's a friend of
his and he goes but it didn't work out
we passed and I go why'd you tell him
and he goes nothing
and I think he said you know if you go
to store to buy a suit and you don't
want it you don't go back and tell them
you don't want it right they figured out
just don't know oh wait let me use I
think I think if I turn it up loud
enough you won't have to hold up your
yeah I'll do it all right I'll do it huh
yeah it's up to you what's up David my
question is what was your worst date
that you ever had and what is the best
way to get out of the path date without
being a jerk game game uh uh and Gehring
brother he gave you a gang gang at the
end and he's from Poland well polish
power huh you didn't call any phone that
he lives here no he lives in Poland yeah
and he hears this yeah this dumb [ __ ]
show okay thank you brother I don't how
to say thank you in Poland but thank you
very much Oh two things okay one was bad
dates which god there's so many you've
been alive bet you've been on some some
[ __ ] recurs bro oh yeah I'm the bad
part of it oh it's not on you have to
take yourself out of the equation
have you ever is it just been so bad
where you'll tell a girl straight up
this is bad I mean I oh I you know
listen if it's bad on I can tell they
don't like me or it's not clicking you
know at this point your life you realize
everyone's trying and ones means well
you just I would try to start with lunch
or something then you can just tap out
after and be polite never be rude and
then I went to go their separate ways it
just doesn't you know it's too mean I've
had it done to me so many times if some
girl would actually like me more which
is weird because when you're in a
position of getting like you know you
get dm's and [ __ ] from girls and to tell
someone you don't like them or the only
about them is very weird yeah very weird
position I was never in it so I was out
girls what it was always the other way
girls would tell you just to give you
the vibe or they wouldn't call like the
Sorrento's thing one girl about 10 years
ago said we at the Rainbow Room just
cool a little joint and she goes she
said she was an actress right so about
halfway through that noise is that you
mm-hmm it's me that elevators me Oh what
do you have in half of a part of a Twix
yeah
nice hot Twix people like when you chew
and talk my mommy's deep paydays because
they were like kind of like the healthy
candy bar
yeah cause it'd be nuts yeah I get it
and she wouldn't let us watch her eat
him she would eat him by herself in a
room that's weirder um I used to put
paydays in the toilet and then say I was
sick and so uh they break apart so I go
to this I go to Rainbow Room and this
girl's like yeah and then her phones
like mmm-hmm and she goes yeah [ __ ] it's
work I go home she goes I have to go to
the valley there was a fallout in an
anal scene no way I go oh you're a adult
porn actress she goes yeah I go yeah she
goes I should probably go I gotta pick
that up you know
hey works work you know and she's like
but I'll probably be done by midnight if
I go you know let's put a pin in that
and we'll uh pick this up later don't
you just do tonight do your thing and
I'm like well there's twice I've been
right I run into porn people yeah I
already know hooker once I didn't I was
a hooker and I rented Oh two girls ever
did porn I don't know but porns wait
common I mean out here horns pretty
common a lot of girls out here is more
you getting let's see a lot of women
that are more the sugar daddy style it's
like dating you know yes I love you for
a couple hundred bucks I'll go on a date
with you and see what happens a bit of a
hybrid hooker well my friend does what's
your price you know that is mm-hmm
the great sales pitches who goes what's
your price you ever seen a girl it's so
pretty the coffee shop you wish you'd go
on one date with her you could win her
over
mm-hmm well you can so he goes on the
site and all these pretty girls in you
go hey how much does it cost to take you
to dinner and they're like 300 bucks he
does this all the time and just kidding
I've seen the girls they meet him for
dinner 300 bucks and then they leave can
you pay him
hmm and there you go yeah no love
connection it's like a business record
they say for another 500 I'll give you a
[ __ ] in the car you know sometimes
you take some home but yeah I thought I
was embrace Li it's just like girls want
to make some money they all go to dinner
with you
sit with you yeah and some guys want to
just puff up and go to [ __ ] catch and
be like hey look who I got
take a hottie out there yeah well
arm-candy old-school yeah do you took me
to catch that one time yeah I take care
of you man like arm candy yeah we did
that fun man you were my arm candy right
I place uh I mean I remember watching
you when we were leaving walking out and
every you would see like like I had like
a couple people that were like oh hey
that's Theo bond you know like a couple
of like comedy fans but you it's
definitely a different thing it feels
like a little bit it almost feels spooky
I feel like being at your level of
popularity you know that's nice I mean I
think by this point you'll learn that
you can get a big head about it but
there's always somebody feel doing
better than you you know I had so many
times he did things didn't work that you
wanted that I think right now most
people know me without even sounding
cocky just after all this time they've
seen you in something but they don't
always like you some people get pictures
it and they rise even bigger this [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but yeah that's the
difference about popularity from like
podcasts and stuff is people are a
little bit more engagement who you are
as a person I feel like yeah you know
and so it's like well you're very real
you've got a different thing which is I
think you're interesting because you
have it your comedies like that is it
you'd think there'd be more like this
there's not just like guys there's me
and you have an interesting life some
people could do this and it wouldn't be
fun to hear you have a good spin on it
you're funny down deep and then you have
an interesting past and present oh it
works it's good it's true I think that's
their whole thing why it worked and I I
one guy tried to trip me up in an
interview and then I probably have to
book it to look up [ __ ] Brea one guy
said when do you think you're the most
famous such a weird question hmm and
what he meant the the real answer was
now because of cumulative from
everything I've done and then there's
more people at now and know me now of
course shows are in reruns this you know
right rules of engagement just shoot me
SNL and then all the movies on TBS every
day at 3 p.m.
oh yeah something's on with me soul if
there's that but he meant I think
did the in the old days cover Rolling
Stone cover of entertain weekly cover TV
Guide that's what he was getting at but
that was a while ago so it was more so
it was a loaded question that you
weren't still as famous I guess I mean
you could ask anyone that and there's
times when you could point to where you
know it's really like up and down your
career you know you know if something
come out for two years than you do then
it doesn't really work and then two
years there's something big so it's
never gonna be like straight level line
some years of better than others but
overall I did make it did make me think
I'm like wow that is a weird question I
don't know but as long as you I think
the hard thing is still doing [ __ ] and
making a living
year after year is hard so if you can do
that it's already praised anyone out
there so my friends are still just Road
comics but they're doing it yeah it's
hard and they bring in a crowd and they
get their bills paid and I [ __ ] it's
hard man do it good job
one last question we have the new SNL
cast number we wanted uh you want to ask
that name yeah well just more of a topic
for you guys to chew on SNL yesterday
announced three new SNL cast members
Chloe finiman Beau and yang who's the
first East Asian descent at first people
were saying first Asian but Rob
Schneider's Filipino a little specific
Thank You Rob I love him sing again with
that with the Filipino I'm West USA
they're really breaking it down and
Shane Gillis and hours after he was
announced a Twitter mob slightly dug
into him they tried to ruin his life and
a resurface video from his podcast came
up where he used the word [ __ ] he was
like kind of playing like a character
they were talking about how let me say
that I looked at that little clip I
thought they were saying like yapanese
people feel like they're number one and
Koreans feel not as good as jazz that
Woody is that what you're talking about
yeah it is I have the clip right here
when I'm sick but it's definitely I
don't know it's gonna be tough for him
because that playing against they just
hired an Asian guy they did
that was the first Asian they hired yes
so it's one of the three guys they hired
someone's getting all this praise Boeing
young oh I see and then the other guy
they dig up something where he says
something seemingly against that what
like I don't even know if he'll survive
it's you don't mean I don't know he put
out apology he said I'm a comedian who
pushes boundaries I sometimes miss if
you go through my ten years of comedy
most of it bad you're going to find a
lot of bad missus I am happy to
apologize to anyone who's actually
offended by anything I've set my
intention is never to hurt anyone but
I'm trying to be the best comedian I can
be and sometimes that requires risks
yeah and how do we expect people to
evolve if they don't have a past if they
don't have any timeline you know it's
like I feel like the online mob has just
become it's just a mob that's what it is
it has no understanding it has no care
concern for well it's very it's it's
hard to just remove people from their
job in life and some people get angry
about different things and just want
someone's life done and they don't see
the after-effects like that is no people
go kill themself take everything wave oh
yeah
now I don't even know about this case in
particular I don't know enough about it
but in general as a comedian you know
used to try to be edgy that was the
whole thing five years ago that's what
you wonder bits no one else is doing you
don't want to steal material like what's
your take on this you're taking this and
who you pushed it oh that bits [ __ ]
crazy you did and now if someone could
go look those up and say you went too
far defended me and now you're out yeah
and that's a tough weird time to be a
comedian it's hard it's just hard every
day on my show I go I open it and say
something because I'm just trying to get
a [ __ ] laugh in that one second
moment right believe me I don't believe
in everything I say I just say it to get
a laugh you want to shock people you
want to say crazy the monologue a lot of
the stuff I'm like oh this is great you
know yeah I mean some people that like
comedy like it then everyone writers him
like do it do it
but I have to think about myself and go
I don't want something to happen over
but how do you get any show off the
ground how do you be different
you don't reviews to go it's the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuz there's probably seven
jokes we're still allowed to use
everyone's like I'm okay with that one
right you can do it yeah it's like
reviewers what if it nowadays it's
almost like it's just if reviewers don't
like you or wouldn't represent just by
being a human living human yeah they
hate you anyway so it's like oh well
it's hard to get ahead and yeah you need
a bag of ass bra thing they're an ass
bag or whatever now it's just thirty you
know million reviewers on Twitter and
Instagram today you hear about like my
last show did old sitcoms there weren't
people on Twitter and Instagram so now
everyone's like here's what I think I'm
like okay so I listen to it I mean some
are here and some hurt my feelings
yeah but I think that the noise has been
so low it's just so it's happened so
much now that it's just almost become a
deaf it's hard yeah I mean there's
comics like Chappelle's special bill
burr first press yeah to get away with
it that's great I think people can again
buddy yeah you just have to be I think
you have to be smart it's hard I hope it
just sort of blows over because I don't
want to see the end of people doing
comedy I know yeah what will happen man
I want to go to the mall in audition
[ __ ] Star Search by the way to wrap
up that story about a couple years later
I got the young comedians special and I
think the next day they said oh you got
Star Search too and I had to turn down
Star Search oh [ __ ] I was waiting all
this time for that they said you can't
do both I got so my stuff here too let
it go and that was something you thought
of would is gonna be your break yeah do
people ever think you're Brad Pitt ever
anybody ever come up to you and thought
you were Brad Pitt
how kid did the other day yeah he
literally is like about 80 goes more you
ain't World War Z I go no but I want to
kiss you I good going guys I go oh
you're eight oh yeah but I the worst is
if Brad Pitt ever gets it you must be
like no I'm not
Bradford's will have a few guys I've run
into out there that's a big sinner needs
a [ __ ] cool dude yeah yeah
whoo okay I mean I don't seem a lot but
yeah for that fame to be cool shocking
yeah how would you even do it David
Spade thanks so much for coming in man
all right thanks I guess we just wrap it
up and say thanks for having me and you
got a good fan base out there I'm glad
to talk to him yeah no man I appreciate
you coming in I hope you crushed it
tonight at Brea or else you gonna be in
the next couple oh I got a mirage
October 4th and 5th that weekend the
Vegas oh nice yeah I do that I'm doing a
couple weekends before the I love that
room
yeah no fun you did it yeah great dude
that room is the bad place is fun yeah
me and Ray Romano it's great oh wow
we've done it we did last year it's
super fun oh you told me about that hour
I think you told me about that so you
guys are both gonna be on say just half
and half kinda yeah yeah and I got
Houston improv coming up and I haven't
looked that many gigs just because it
shows so [ __ ] old along yeah but I'll
be out there shaking my chromium I love
it staying busy thanks brother All Right
see you guys
[Music]
when I reach that round I'll share this
piece of my my I can feel it in my bones
thought it's gonna take
little time for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]